que c'est vrai qu'on vit une
époque violente on vit une époque où où
il y a du racisme à
l'emploi du racisme au
logement des violences
policières mais à la fin de la fin
messieurs dames n'oubliez jamais une
chose
essentielle c'est que la France est un
bon
pays
il y a pas de chute
hein non mais c'est vrai je crois ce que
je viens de dire je des Reno me regarde
ouais renoin tu voas trop loin là non
mais je suis sincère hein non les gars
non la France n un bon pays il est temps
de remettre l'église au centre du
village la France est un bon pays
messieurs dames mais la France c'est
quand même un pays où tu peux te lever
le
matin être au chômage avoir des aides
voire même que le Président de la
République vient dans ta ville aller à
sa rencontre et lui fout une de
claque dans la gueule vive la République
vive la France messieurs dames oui mon
ami c'est ça notre pays un pays où tu
peux gifler normal le président pas
I